رغم توفر محتويات جديده دائما على القنوات
التلفزيونيه او المنصات عبر الانترنت الا
ان الكثيرين يفضلون اعاده مشاهده بعض
المسلسلات والافلام مرارا وتكرارا كثيرون
يخفون يوميا وهم يعيدون مشاهده مسلسل مثلا
فرانس للمره العشرين دون ملل بل ويشعرون
بسعاده كبيره بعد متابعه عمل فني او
برنامج تلفزيوني شاهدوه من قبل يبدو ان
هناك سببا علميا وراء ذلك
فوفقا لثود كتالوج الامر لا يتعلق بحب هذه
الاعمال وتفضيلها عن غيرها لكنه يرتبط
بالسعاده وجلب الطاقه الايجابيه بسبب
استعاده الذكريات تمثل فرحه كبيره لهم
يرتبط الشعور بالسعاده بعد مشاهده الاعمال
الفنيه القديمه بعده اسباب تكون معا عوامل
الشعور بالسعاده اولها عدم وجود عنصر
مفاجاه فمعرفه الاحداث يجلب لك شعورا
بالارتياح مع الانتباه للتفاصيل الصغيره
التي قد تكون لم تلاحظها من قبل بالاضافه
الى الحنين لاوقات مميزه في حياتنا خاصه
تلك المرتبطه بالتذكر وقت محدد في حياتنا
وبعد الاعمال القديمه تعيدون الى فتره
الطفوله او الحب الاول او ذلك الرابط
القوي مع صديق قديم ربما شاهدتم نفس العمل
سويا
وعندما نشاهد العروض او الافلام القديمه
فاننا بالفعل نعرف الاحداث لذا يمكن
متابعتها بسهوله دون الحاجه الى التركيز
او بذل كثير من الجهد المعرفي لمعالجه
الاحداث وتحليلها اعاده مشاهده عمل فني مع
ارتباطك بالشخصيات يعيد اليك مشاعر محببه
كرؤيه صديق قديم فالمشاعر التي تثيرها
الشخصيات المالوفه تشعر المشاهد بالدعم
والراحه كما ان بعض الذكريات تلهمنا
للتواصل مره اخرى مع الاصدقاء القدامى
التي ربما انقطعنا عن التواصل معهم ما
يزيد من الترابط الاجتماعي على كل حال
سالنا الناس ما هو العمل الفني الذي لا
تمل من اعاده مشاهدته نتابع
العمل اللي انا مبملش منه مسلسل عبد
الغفور البرعي هو بالنسبه لي لو قديم على
طول هي ممكن المسرحيات يعني انا بحب
المسرحيات مثلا شاهد او المشاغبين الحاجات
دي بالنسبه لي انا زي ما تقول تراث كده
ومهما اتفرج عليهم
العيال الحلميه
مسرحيه العيال كبرت فيلم كل افلامنا
القديمه بس العمل الحقيقي لا اقعد اتفرج
عليه خالص
فيلم كده رضا بتاع احمد حلو العمل الفني
اللي انا مش بزهق منه راجل وست ستات او
مسلسل اللص والكتاب اي عمل لسامح حسين انا
بحبه
[موسيقى]
على كل من الكويت ينضم لنا اختصاصي نفسي
عبد الناصر علاء سيد عبد الناصر اهلا بك
معنا في العربيه
نفسيا من ناحيه نفسيه لماذا يعيد بعض
الاشخاص مشاهده برامج او افلام شاهدوها
قبل هل هو الحنين الى الماضي او محاوله او
استرجاع المتعه التي شعروا بها عند مشاهده
تلك البرامج او الافلام
اولا صباح الخير صباح الخير
للساده المشاهدين وصباح الخير لك سهام
ونادين وخليني ادخل في الموضوع بشكل سريع
هو ان زي ما انتم عملتم في التقرير بتاعكم
معظم الناس اللي انتم سالتوهم كانوا
بالدور اجابتهم حوالين ان احنا لما بنشوف
الافلام دي او لما بنرجع مره ثانيه نشغل
المسلسلات دي دي بتخلينا نبقى مبسوطين
كتير الانسان بطبعه دايما بيدور في الحياه
طول ما هو عايش من اول ما بيبدا يومه لحد
ما بينهي ايه الاشياء اللي ممكن اعملها
تخليني مبسوط وفي الاغلب
في الاغلب ما بيلاقيش الحاجات اللي بتخليه
مبسوط وسعيد الا لما بيرجع بذاكرته لورا
فيلم شافه وهو طفل مسلسل تابعه مع اصحابه
وهو مراهق كان في الوقت ده كان
ما كانش فيه كم الضغوط اللي موجود عليه
دلوقتي يكمل مسئوليات فمعظم الناس بتحاول
ترجع بالذاكره لوراء وتبدا تهرب من كم
الضغوط اللي هي بتعيشها في الحاضر وكمل
مسئوليات الكبيره جدا الا ان هي تعيش شعور
هو اسير عاداته
يكررها ويشعر بالراحه والفرح
الانسان اسير عاداته مش هتفق شويه مع
المصطلح ده لكن خليني اقول ان الانسان
والعاده هما وجهين لعمله واحده الانسان هو
عباره عن مجموعه عادات اتكونت اتكونت في
طفولته اتكونت في مراهقته اتكونت في شبابه
وبالتالي الانسان مش اسير عادته هو
الانسان اتعود على شويه سلوكيات اصبحت
السلوكيات دي جزء من يومه
جزء من حياته
بتخليه مبسوط او بتخليه حزين بتخليه سعيد
او بتخليه متضايق وللاسف هو ده اللي
بيخلينا نشوف في بعض المرات ليه بعض الناس
بتحاول ان هي تقرر نفس السلوكيات ونفس
العادات اللي بتعملها ليه لان هي العادات
دي في حياتها يعني هذه السلوكيات والعادات
لا تنطبق فقط على التلفزيون على البرامج
والافلام ولكن حتى مثلا مجال السفر يعيدوا
نفس المناطق يزوروها على مثلا الاكل في
نفس المطعم قائمه الط عام طويله بيطلبوا
نفس الطبق كل مره كيف يمكن شرح ذلك نفسيا
اول حاجه اول حاجه خلينا نتفق ان كل سلوك
الانسان عمله في الماضي اتشكل مع السلوك
ده مجموعه من المشاعر ومجموعه من الافكار
ولما بيبدا الانسان مره تانيه يحتاج ان هو
يعيش شعور مثلا زي شعور الفرح فهو
بالتحديد بيدور في الارشيف بتاع ذاكرته
وهنا بنبدا نبحث في الذاكره بعيده المدى
هي ايه الاشياء اللي انا لما عملتها في
السابق كانت مخلياني مبسوط وكانت مخلياني
سعيد هنا الانسان ما بيحاولش يعمل مجهود
هو هنا الانسان بيبحث عن المشاعر بس بابسط
الاشياء فهي ايه ابسط الاشياء اللي ممكن
تخليني مبسوط هو ان انا ارجع بذاكرتي
الورق افتكر مكان معين كنت مبسوط فيه او
افتكر اشخاص معينين كنت ببقى سعيده اما
بتكلم معاهم او مكان ارتبط فيه بعض
المشاعر مكان معين حسيت فيه بالاسترخاء
لان انا كنت مشدود في فتره من فترات حياتي
فهتلاقيني بروح لنفس المكان ده حتى لو ما
اروحه جسديا او ماديا عندي ظروف تمنعني ان
انا اروح ممكن اعمل ده حتى في خيالي ممكن
اعمل ده في احلام اليقظه وخليني اقول ان
جزء من العادات اللي ممكن بتخلي الانسان
برضو يرجع بذاكرته لورا هو هي فكره ان
تكون اتكونت عنده احلام يقظه احلام يقظه
عن ان دايما الماضي فيه حاجات جميله فهو
دايما لما بيحلم بيرجع في الماضي فشكل من
اشكال الاحلام اليقظه هي فكره ان الانسان
يرجع للماضي الماضي ده فيه ايه الماضي ده
شاف فيلم دخل مسرحيه قعد مع اصحابه في
قعده حلوه قعد في مطعم شرب شرب عصير لطيف
شارب فنجان قهوه في مكان هادي وبيحبه فده
كمان بيشكل جزء من المشاعر اللي الانسان
بيعيشها فمن الوقت للتاني بيرجع للمشاعر
دي حتى لو عن طريق الخيال شكرا جزيلا من
الكويت الاختصاصي النفسي عبد الناصر علي